president biden and the first lady are
heading to surfside florida this morning
to visit the site of last week's
catastrophic building collapse
search teams found the bodies of two
young children yesterday they were only
four
and 10 years old their parents were also
found yesterday bringing the death toll
to 18.
145 people are still missing today
omar villafranca is in surf side with
more on the story
omar good morning to you has anything
changed at the site this morning
uh well good morning gail we're not
seeing cranes by this building this
morning there are reports
that search and rescue operations might
have been paused overnight over safety
concerns from that building
we hope to learn a little bit more at a
media debrief later on this morning
we're also hearing from people who were
inside the building who narrowly escaped
the collapse one woman was asleep and
she heard a loud crash that woke her up
and she called her brother
and in the chilling voicemail you can
hear her reaction
and the chaos that's going on around her
take a listen
oh my god
what the hell oh my god
yeah the whole advice is going
on rescue crews have actually built a
ramp to bring in heavier equipment which
will hopefully
speed up the process where they can
remove more of that pulverized concrete
and at this point it's a race against
time
because officials and everyone is really
watching two systems in the gulf that
are churning
that may be heading this way gail
story's still so agonizing thank you
very much omar
cbs news will bring you a 30-minute
special it's called surfside collapse
the search for answers tonight at 8
o'clock eastern on our streaming network
cbsn
you don't already have the app please
download the cbs news app so you can see
it